[Applause]
holiday the crossover
stolen by deandre ayton
paul pushes back to booker up top
crowder
bridges fakes now drives extra pass
great ball movement but terrific defense
as well
booker trying to draw the foul hooked
away by middleton
bridges inside ayton for the layout and
the foul
what a sequence
how many passes were made
and nine great scrambling
by the bucks to close out deflections
but a beautiful
pass by bridges to eight coach
normandale would have been proud of that
possession
and this is the first free throw of the
game for the phoenix suns
now that's one of the the keys you guys
talked about
the bucks wanted to keep the suns off
the free throw line they've done that
i'd say just chemistry trust um
believing in your brother believing in
your teammate
and we actually talked about that play
right after the game me and mikael
he was i think that was the most pumped
i've been after play i was like me too
the same year so you know when you're
playing like that
you know it's fun it's fun everybody's
touching it you feel the energy of the
ball when you get it you know you want
to make a play for somebody else and
somebody
something opens up always when you know
it's popping and moving like that